welcome to the lab spin calm podcast
hey guys what's up its Dylan from laughs
pencom welcome to another episode of The
Laugh spin podcast thank you so much for
joining us if you were not a subscriber
to the podcast please go to itunes or
SoundCloud and subscribe if you already
are a subscriber thank you so much i
truly do appreciate it this episode of
the last spin podcast I talked to
comedian Ralphie May legendary Ralphie
May the dude is prolific he has seven
stand-up comedy specials he just
released his latest it's called unruly
it's on Netflix it's uh it's pretty
solid man so check it out obviously if
you're a Ralphie May fan you're gonna
love it Ralphie and I spoke we chatted
we hung out in his in his tour van this
was the day before he was scheduled to
do Howard Stern he took some time out we
talked a lot we talked a lot actually
but it was good we did a lot we went
deep we talked about a lot of stuff you
guys so um I'm gonna shut up here's
Ralphie I feel humbled as you're you're
going to Howard Stern tomorrow and
you're talking and you're talking to me
today don't worry about so we are aboard
just to set the stage for everyone we're
aboard Ralphie's a super cool tour bus
that has Ralphie's name do you get do
you get knocks on your door because I
mean this is not you are not incognito
here Ralphie no I'm not I i do get
occasionally people it's weird when a
drunk girls show up and and it's like we
want to buy it and edit that's when I go
to the back of the [ __ ] bus hotel I
torv
of support guys to [ __ ] to show them
get them out of here yeah yeah get-get
best get that liability get that yeah
the [ __ ] away from me Hey yeah it's true
you know people think it's it's all fun
and games but I mean you're you're an
adult and you don't want that you don't
want that mess no no well I'm also
married and it's like I like all my [ __ ]
you know that's the thing you know guys
who cheat on their wives you must not
like all your [ __ ] all right you know
you gonna lose the f of it and I'm not
about to know sir but you know plus it's
just a dick thing to do you know it's
like he's got that much time to be that
much of an [ __ ] to somebody you're
supposed to love you know yeah he's got
that drama not me I don't know man I
don't know what about did you'd come
knocking what about it's just a dude
that just want to say hey it's a lot of
dudes who want to come smoke weed with
me like that and it's like I don't smoke
weed all the time you know and rights
not like and you know it's like
sometimes I have my [ __ ] family on
the bus and it's like hey bro it's my
[ __ ] kids right you know I mean it's
like relax yeah yeah but I guess that
happens to people i know a guy who went
up to Dave Grohl and was like let's
party let's get [ __ ] up it days I
guess my kids my mother law is like it's
like okay god bless you you know yeah
people don't you know they see they see
that person on stage and that's it
that's all that's all even though i mean
it's it's not like you don't talk about
i mean your newest special you know he
mentioned your kids you have that entire
bit where you were you a dream where you
address your son which is awesome it
like still they just they wanna i think
they just want to be part of like the
what a party section yeah and you know
it's weird because like we went on a
Disney cruise and people are coming up
to me going is that the that the boy who
grabbed the the girls [ __ ] in the
elevator and I'm right yeah that's it
alright and so my son his pyrazole walk
around all these adults go yeah that's
him that's him ain't go straight to his
[ __ ] head because straight to his
head eight things he's a badass dude but
it's it's like changing his behavior you
know people's people's reaction to him
is changing his behavior he's he's
getting more and more blatant about
about stuff like he one of his buddies
mom is really hot right this is La all
the moms are super [ __ ] hot okay and
and my son grabbed this mom's ass and
and I asked him you know this was days
later son why did you do that and he
even told her this I had to daddy just
look so good I had to grab it you know
um you can't fault him for being honest
you know he just gotta go hey I'm with
you man I've seen some hotel before you
know where there's five or fifty five it
you know the truth is the [ __ ] truth
yeah and hey it was a man consumed but I
told him I go that's not nice you can't
do it the people and they're gonna get
mad and so far he hasn't had that
experience but I keep on telling you
know they're gonna gonna gonna spank you
but I gotta throw your jail yeah he's
like I don't care I don't care daddy I
gotta do how old is seen he's five now
or live Wow yeah I have it's I mean I
enjoy when when comics kind of like open
up a little bit about their kids on
stage I have two boys six year old and a
three year old
okay so right behind ya yep yep so I
hadn't you how old your daughter seven
oh wow okay got it got it do they get
along yes really well really well yeah
yeah my wife has done an amazing job
like if it was up to me my kids would be
raised by wolves yeah I mean I mean I'm
a [ __ ] dad all right but my wife is
amazing you know it's where my children
are a happy well-adjusted healthy
children you know is all because of my
wife yeah zero to do with me really yes
don't give yourself any credit is 00
buggy credit 0 I am I of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm a narcissist ok there which
are very too bad eggs fights against you
as far as being a good parent oh yeah
I'm gone all the time I work i'm a good
provider but that means that i'm gone
all the time so no it's weird you know
you don't have until you have kids you
don't realize how much like stand-up
wasn't ever a job to me right until I
had kids and now it's like now they
don't pay for the jokes they never paid
for the jokes they they just pay for me
not to be in my house next to my wife
next to my kids well right that's what
they pay their money for yeah yeah it
becomes it becomes very real like yeah
I'm sure before you had a family you
know thoughts would go through your head
where it's like well I could stop if I
want right not that you you know not
that you would want to stop but now it's
like well this is it I'm in it now I
have to I have people to keep alive ya
know I've people to keep alive that's
true but you know I still think a lot
about quitting really yeah you know I
mean it's like I've done it for 25 years
yeah you know I mean it's like what what
more do you have to do a little more do
you have to prove yeah I mean you know I
mean you're in the top 1% yeah stand-up
comics yep you know I
never conquer New York I never conquered
LA but that's okay I never really gave a
[ __ ] about conquer neither one of those
I was really happy with the 300 million
in between yeah you know and you know a
lot of people said that as their goal to
be you know that person none that's
never did I just kept on doing specials
and making people laugh you know that's
just I don't know is I was never the
cooling you know when you're not the hip
cool comic all right you know it's weird
the guys I thought work or either dead
or quit you know and it is it's like
there's no good it's like your buddies
are gone or you don't get to see your
buddies right you know now then now that
an indictment is a conviction you can't
go watch stand-up comics because if
someone says you ripped off my bed ok
that's enough to kill your career yeah
all right you know it's like just the
accusation is enough to kill your career
yeah and and like you said I've got
people right you know so that takes a
lot of the joy out of stand-up comedy
because now I can't even watch stand-up
comedy right thing I love the most I
can't watch anymore right because I'm in
it now and it's like and I right so fast
and I right so much it's that and
without opportunity there can be no
theft and so I just keep myself off you
know that's what people submit you know
people send me videos of themselves you
know hey help me out and right I can you
don't even look at I don't even look at
it I can't open it I can't I can't do
anything because I can't allow my career
to be in your accusation you know right
i mean in comics are crazy you know i
mean somebody will see something but one
use one word you know and they'll go
[ __ ] nuts and
and just start shouting and that's all
you have to say and then boom it's over
yeah you know and so I don't even allow
myself to be [ __ ] even in the same
sentence as joke thievery because I'm
never in the [ __ ] room when it jokes
being said right has there been had did
something ever happen that I don't I've
seen so many guys over 25 years okay
yeah I was the victim of it of a lot of
jealousy in Houston Texas when I first
started out of people saying he's a joke
thief okay then you go what what joke
did he taken they wouldn't have an
answer for you right all right and and
it got to be the point where everybody
started calling [ __ ] on you know
guys from out of town we call [ __ ]
on the Houston comics because they
couldn't give him a [ __ ] answer right
you know and and and then and then
somebody who wasn't just in houston
would be like you know everybody's
talking about that around the country
what do you hate it I mean that's not a
bug it's a pretty beaten up premise you
know you know whether it was [ __ ] a
Lorena Bobbitt or or [ __ ] you know
whatever back story was in the news ok
that every comic was talking about all
right you know these stories they get
beaten up but if you're in your own
shallow pool you think you originated it
and that anybody who does anything near
it is joke thieve okay and they used it
against me to try to drive me out of
stand-up comedy because I was 18 19 and
taken their gigs yeah you know I mean
when Bill Hicks came to town and had me
open for him I've pissed a lot of
[ __ ] people yeah I can imagine I you
know I mean and Bill wanna me because I
was a young and dumb and didn't know any
better didn't know what he was doing you
know I I was just doing my little [ __ ]
comedy and I wasn't I was the only one
who wasn't trying to be him
right you know and and and so that dude
cause more and when Sam Kinison taps
yeah all right you know its first it
seems like a blessing and then you
realize it's a [ __ ] cars amongst your
parents you know I mean it's like they
they [ __ ] hated that those guys like
to me all right and you know it was
weird because later on the only one and
we laugh about it the only one that made
it out of it was dougie Stanhope yeah
the me and Doug east and I was like who
would have thought that he and I would
still be alive all this time okay oh you
know we we where the two that we will go
really EE really really bitchin Berg's
god okay so many great guys are gone and
and it's just it's like we're the ones
that keep on truckin and it's so funny
is that Stanhope's had me at his death
pool since he started it okay and he
he's like I know what these years you're
gonna pay off but you keep on [ __ ]
living okay you're [ __ ] be up here bed
it's like I gotta have the inside track
on you and then so this year was the
first year that he was like I don't
think I'm gonna put you in the pool oh
my god I think I got some better people
then it goes not the last second I had
to put yes just cuz I thought I'd put
the jinx on you for sure okay the way
time I don't pick you boo that's when
you die I it's like lottery numbers
someone okay you know is so funny you
know but dougie and and Joey Diaz and
myself we never should have made it out
those guys should have been dead a long
time ago I should have been too you know
yeah we we made it all up so far so yeah
I mean you mentioned you really got
started young I mean you've yeah Savitt
a yeah so born born in Chattanooga right
raised in Arkansas yes and then at what
point then you move to Houston yeah I'm
OT Houston before I I didn't even get to
graduate
I left uh eight days before grad all
right so I just left I don't even
[ __ ] from your from your school in
Arkansas yeah why did you why did you
get kicked out pranks pranks alive what
kind of products a lot of stupid [ __ ]
you know and it's weird now that that
you know all the statue of limitations
are over but the way it is now the way
America is now yeah it would be on CNN
and it would be ATF would be involved
yeah okay I mean we we did a lot of
stuff that that you know very
destructive thanks to our rival school
okay and they did very destructive
thanks to us to the point where you know
they we got our bus stopped they rode
burning bales of hay in the streets okay
then and then pelted the the bus okay
you know it was it was a whole school
ambush okay Helton with with what ah
with bricks rocks Jesus eggs a [ __ ]
supposedly there was gunplay but i don't
know i don't think so i don't think so i
don't know it was a lot of mailing I
mean when you're in a bus a [ __ ]
brick hitting it okay sounds a lot like
a gunshot yeah okay and you know a lot
of the the impact and the explosion of
glass is about the same yeah and it was
it was a crazy you know crazy school
year but I am I had gotten I was
involved in the University of Arkansas
beginning Scholars Program and I got to
go to school University of Arkansas and
that certain ideas what allowed me to
get into the stand up contest to open up
for Sam Kinison
which started everything you know it's
like that one thing if I had to fill it
out that one piece of paper at the
insistence of my school counselor I
would have never done stand-up right and
said it's like you look back and you
know usually it's it's the the teacher
that inspires you or are you know
positive or negative for me it was a
counselor go and fill this piece of
paper out be something fun to do in the
summer right you know and that was that
was the start of it all had you
expressed interest in comedy to your
counselor or he just no no no not not
not at comedy to my counselor but I I've
done stand-up comedy before I done it at
13 m 1985 at a church youth camp it was
a five states a youth panel thing and
they had a talent show i won I was 13 I
made out with a 14 year old grace finger
blasted her okay she's from prattville
alabama okay and she's cute a big hair I
remember big sure and not that big Bush
but me I'm probably probably I don't
remember but big hair like her hair was
big um it was it was a crazy thing you
know it's it's weird that that's been my
motivation throughout my whole career
has just been women I you know when I
won the talent show contest of the week
before to get into to get to the
attention of everyone there was an open
mic contest at the shakey's pizza my
study group from college we were all
meeting up and and you know just I can
hang out then a stand-up comedy contest
and they're like do it do it do it and
so I did it and I got a bull job
afterwards from an unattractive girl by
a dumpster out back okay
and I was [ __ ] [ __ ] college all right
this was this was after the show it was
ok ok ok I was like [ __ ] college this is
it is no one ever sucked my dick because
I got a [ __ ] a you know an organic
chemistry ok you know a Nolan gave me
[ __ ] and so it was definitely something
that I was like this is this is what I
want to do you know and it's so silly
now to think that's it you made a life
decision alright and you stuck with it
you [ __ ] lucky enough to come out on
top you know it's like no one no one is
more baffled by my success than me yeah
I think that's what that's probably one
of the things that I think people don't
understand is that I've nobody's more
shocked than I that does happen and it
all started with that I mean really with
it with the Kinison thing so you were
what 17-18 you were 17 so did you I mean
did you interact with him or was he like
how did what was that like I did to a
degree it's like you could hang out with
Sam until like 1130 at night alright and
then it was you get a little evil mm-hmm
and for me it was like going to a sim
Kennison party at 17 was no place for a
17 year old boy I'm 43 now and it's no
place for me now yeah okay I mean rails
of blow and and I mean just a lot of
craziness around him but he would be
nice you know until about eleven thirty
you know that fourth or fifth key
bumping and he's really starting to rage
and starting to get angry and that's
when I would just [ __ ] disappear yeah
cuz that's when the gun would come out
you know he had a 45 that he liked tote
around
right gun would come out and [ __ ] what
happened you know not good yeah so even
at that young age you knew this isn't
cool no good sorry [ __ ] cool like
don't hang around I knew what guns do
you know yeah market saw you know you
you've been hunting you for 10 years at
that point it's like I know what guns
can do I don't would be anywhere [ __ ]
arrow right yeah if you know what they
are you know you kinda you develop a
healthy respect for I think you know
dumb [ __ ] who told them around the
waist of their britches and if I can
shoot sideways I'm really if I can say
what guns can do yeah up close you know
you take a dearest life and you [ __ ]
hold it and you realize this is life and
death and this is like you know you damn
sure better honor the [ __ ] animal and
damn sure better realize that this
animal was just alive until you pull the
[ __ ] trigger yeah I and that I think
is a great thing for people to learn and
they would have more responsibility for
the weapons in their possession you know
that's a good point I mean I never I
never thought of it like that i mean i'm
from this area you know we're right
outside of new york and guns just always
scared the [ __ ] out of me and you know
it was just never part of my culture so
so you know when I see like hunters I'm
like I don't know hunting is seems kind
of you know it's just it's just foreign
to me yeah the way you just described it
I mean that makes sense to me yeah it
kinda and you know it's like people
always say it's barbaric and and yes it
is but then the essence of nature is
barbaric it's very true I mean it's like
the civilized thing that we've become is
only because of higher you know you know
evolution you know with our minds and
and like you know that only came about
through added protein through the
ingestion of meat right okay so the very
way we become self-aware and to to have
enough guilt in our life
to seek you know and and to be honestly
to be so blessed with so much food that
we could choose to be a vegetarian or
pescetarian or vegan or or friggin or
whatever the [ __ ] you are okay right
it's that you know all that came about
because of the added protein from eating
meat developed our cerebral cortex okay
without we would never have involved all
right so it's like the the action of
eating meat has caused people to revolt
away from wanting to eat me it's like
it's like the right there's
self-consciousness they don't understand
right you know it's like it's like the
people like my wife is always bitching
about a like because she's a Jew and
she's bitching about Christmas about the
Christmas tree how it's a killing of a
life and I'm like yeah but what about
those cedar-lined closets we bought all
right about those houses we live in what
are they [ __ ] made of you know what I
mean it's like yeah pick your [ __ ]
battle so yeah I don't be don't be
bitching about like it you've met about
a tree's life but yet you throw paper
away all the time okay you know it's
like just doc a little [ __ ] okay just
just stow it all right just stop your
[ __ ] you know it is like you can't tell
everybody that you know you want to I
would desperately love to tell people
just on there and call people on their
[ __ ] you're right that's why I would
make I'm not saying I make a great
politician all right i'm saying i would
be a very entertaining polity yeah okay
he probably wouldn't go far in politics
cuz you're too honest too honest and you
know I think that's that would be a
refreshing change you don't have some
yeah Hey look all I want to be here for
any years I want to make a positive
change I got two kids okay uh let's work
together all right
and I want to call people sons of
[ __ ] who are sons of [ __ ] I and
and and you tell me what you think and
I'll fight for you okay all right and
that's what I like you know that would
be a refreshing breath of air when it
comes into a politics nowadays having
everybody so full of [ __ ] you know it'd
be nice to have somebody to go hey those
people are dumb [ __ ] okay you know why
not legalize marijuana let's text the
[ __ ] out of it yeah all right let's we
got debt to pay off why not you know why
not make money on it you know we [ __ ]
there's so much stupid [ __ ] you know
that you would get fixed if we just had
a mind to do it you don't we like we
like if I could you know status quo well
I mean there there you go that's your
that could be your post comedy career
yeah politics do you do actually I mean
I know we talked about it at the very
beginning to you I mean do you seriously
considering do you seriously consider
just like hanging it up and I mean
you've got what six specials 77 specials
I mean you've like you said you've
you've you've conquered it you've
conquered what I got love to do I don't
know would you miss it probably here but
I miss it now here even though I get to
do stand-up comedy and I'm around
stand-up comedy I don't really get to be
around stand-up comics yeah you know so
I miss it now yeah you know I I love us
I think we're the most interesting
people on the planet all right and we're
[ __ ] up and messed up and that only
adds to the interestingness yeah you
know it's find comics to be amazingly
intriguing male or female I think we're
[ __ ] okay we're [ __ ] individuals and
and it's a weird that there's more of
[ __ ] individuals now than there ever
has been it's like it's like we've bred
in our country we have a certain
elevation that we've taken people that
you know that are told so much in their
lives that
you know everything is is you're a
winner too you know like everybody gets
a trophy we're not keeping score right
okay and you've grown up and like been
told that [ __ ] okay that nobody
keeps score and y'all are [ __ ] mad
now that people really keep [ __ ]
school you know I mean you're you're
pissed off and you have a right to be
you know when they said you know we're
all winners what do you mean I've got to
have responsibilities and debt and
[ __ ] hey I'm a winner I got a trophy
yeah all right yeah what the [ __ ] you
know it's easy you know it's like you
know and if everybody wants to be cave
painters you notice that you know it's
like what do you mean by that you know
there was like cave painting there was a
guy the [ __ ] that was his [ __ ] right
that was his I like I Drive the best
buffalo with the best horses and our
guys kill all right and that was one guy
right depicted life of the knee of the
Neanderthal man yeah okay that was one
out of thousands and thousands of people
all right not everybody can be a cave
painter somebody's got to go out there
and fight a saber-toothed tiger right
you know coming and it's like now
nowadays people want to be comedians
instead of being a [ __ ] transmission
repair man okay or where is they used to
have other jobs now so many people are
focused on the arts and swear it's sort
of a renaissance but at the same time
it's [ __ ] okay it's like the that
whereas the Renaissance gave birth to
masters of art that train and and and we
had a you know a genesis in human
evolution today it's people aren't
getting smarter they're getting dumber
to the use of technology they're not
creating masters of art the programming
you know
a a piece of art instead of creating it
ok and the subtlety is is not lost on me
and it's not lost on they are you know
what I mean yeah and and it's the same
with stand-up comedy you know it's like
nobody is doing stand-up comedy for
themselves and they been doing it at
nine years at a minimum yeah until then
you're just an amalgamation of your
favorite influences right okay and then
what some real [ __ ] happens to you then
you have your own voice and then you
could talk you can set about doing your
own thing so you spend the first
basically 10 years of this learning what
not to do okay and then after that 10
years now now you're into it's just like
high school all right you're just you're
still in you're still in high school
you're not even graduated yet okay much
less be functioning like a 25 years I
feel like I'm a master stand-up comedy
but I don't know when that transition
happened from [ __ ] neophyte [ __ ]
to the master stand-up comedy you know
what I mean yeah it's like somewhere
around the way I learned enough to FICA
pick it up but you know just some sheer
volume you know 14 hours of recorded
material in 10 years you know I don't
think anybody's ever done that and you
know as far as respect goes I don't get
any but that's okay because I got checks
it's all right what do you what do you
mean you know you don't you don't feel
like you you're you're respected like as
as know as a comic no no I'm easily
dismissed because I'm overweight but um
you know it's funny how my stand-up
comic my stand-up doesn't really um rely
on my physicality you know I'm I get
smaller on stage not not bigger yeah and
and I don't draw as much emphasis as a
lot of big comics I mean if they're a
little bit overweight I mean Jim
Gaffigan for example is not overweight
at all but all he talks about is food
and being fat right you know he's got
way more fat jokes and I do
all right and and honestly they're
really good you know I can't fault him
for it all right um but it's just not
something that I wanted to be and and
because of that I mean I don't feel the
level I mean if I was somebody else and
had the we just what I'd ahead just for
one hour specials on on comedy central
no one had ever done that before you
think i would get some respect from
Comedy Central hmm what in in what form
would that respect potentially come well
the only thing you can have respect and
be shown respect by a network is an
invitation to do a TV show whether the
TV show goes or not is one thing but
I've never even been allowed to have the
conversation Wow and so you know it's
it's it's okay you know I mean I I'm
very okay I don't see any shame in being
famous for being a stand-up comedian
that's what I'm am I'm famous for being
a stand-up comedian not on TV I never
had a television show carry me right you
know i mean even even the show I did do
was a stand-up comedy competition right
you know what I mean it's like like I
don't have the sitcom I don't have the
movies you know the care of me I've got
to go do it the old-fashioned way I've
got to go win the people where where
they are right i can't go to their TV
then i'll go to their theater right you
know close to them and whereas i don't
do the big arena tours you know I'll do
more volume of people because I do more
shows you know and i'll sell more
tickets because i hustle more right and
i'm fine with that you know that to me
never seem like a big deal you know it
was just like it's a joy to work you
know it's a pleasure it's a gift but
it is um aggravating that you don't get
you know get the respective of other
comics comics of doing it for nothing
you know and I've had a pretty easy ride
but you know partially based on the
legacy that guys like me I mean we can't
stand up alive after the bus of the 80s
in the 90s men I mean clubs were
shutting down you know if it wasn't for
guys like us keeping it going it with a
[ __ ] died out yeah and and you know
it was I don't know it's it just seems
that you know the respect that stand-up
comics get in other car parts of the
world are more than they get here yeah
and you know we're the lowest rung of
entertainment in in in America and yet
it's the hardest job you know yeah where
the individual writers where the
performer where the director where the
producer and and you nobody else has to
do that and it's [ __ ] the closest
thing to it is a band and to be honest
they've got so many people and autotune
helping them I mean how would you like
to have a [ __ ] button that can be
pushed that make your jokes forty
percent funny you know I mean you know
every [ __ ] awesome at me but I want
to butch every [ __ ] day and that's
what auto tube basically is just making
them forty percent better yeah sound
better and it's like what the [ __ ] you
know why are we uh why are we like this
you know it's like why can't we just do
I don't know yeah no I get it I mean
that's I totally agree with you you you
guys are I mean that's why ten years ago
I started interviewing and writing about
comics because nobody was nobody was
doing it nobody the only time people the
only time you would see an article or
something about a comic was in like the
regional you know newspaper in the
entertainment section when they were
coming to your town that
you know Ralphie May is coming to
whatever town and Meers you know here's
an interview with them you know to get
you know people in the seats so yeah I
mean I I totally agree it's just it's
it's interesting to hear and I mean I'm
sure people who are listening to this
it's it's interesting to hear somebody
who you know on the surface you know
very successful selling out theaters all
across the country you know still has
those those doubts and those and those
feelings of you know why why have I been
sort of kind of relegated to I don't
know clown status or you know like
where's my respect yeah yeah you still
get that I think I think that's a that
probably goes back to child and you know
wanted it respect you know that's
probably would stand up comics you know
about that's probably one of the
triggers that makes us is the is the one
for dignity yeah I know the desire for
it you know and you know that
self-approval you know you have to have
thousands of people laugh at everything
you say write me entertained I mean
there's something broken that drives
that yeah that the desire for
qualification to you know to love me
yeah I mean that's a [ __ ] thing to
and I don't want to come off sound like
a [ __ ] whiny acid no you come off as
a human and grateful to you know things
I've had you know but you know it with
it with it would it be nice to get the
recognition from your peers yes would it
be nice to the recognition from Comedy
Central guess but you know I have to
remember as I'm older and stand-up
comedy than then Comedy Central you know
I started before them and so I can't be
mad at them for you know I I didn't get
into him and for stand-up comedy for
comedy central right you know I got into
it for me right and it wasn't even an
option that
so I always think that even though it's
a player now it's not a player in my
mind if it's not in my world you know
what I mean it yeah something I can't I
can't lose thoughts over our time over
worried about what they're going to do
with me because who even knows what the
[ __ ] happening over there sure I mean
it's like inside there you know what
what's going on you know who are they
being told or funny who are they seeing
of funny who where are they going to see
funny that all these are going to skew
you know everything that they ever
judges do they make and people look to
them as the authorities they set
themselves up as the authority of
stand-up comedy but you know they're
really not they miss huge swathes of
stand-ups I mean huge just gaping holes
in stand-up comedy map all right they
they've missed and they've never touched
on you know there's a whole segment of
southern comedians that have never been
[ __ ] thought of you know everybody
goes the blue-collar guys in which you
know Jeff is from Georgia but Larry's
from Nebraska and and bills from Texas
and tighter some Texas but the really
only southern comic was Ron White ya
know and Ron toward for years and well
he got out of comedy eventually you know
he was he was you know he was a southern
comic but there's this huge swathes of
guys that are [ __ ] amazing that no
one's ever heard of and and women are
underserved in that department to even
more so than the men these men are given
a shot once in a while to do some kind
of TV shattered radio [ __ ] whereas the
women aren't even given that chance I
know too that are [ __ ] hilarious as
balls it's so [ __ ] funny all right
and they're not giving a chance at all
and it's a shame yeah the [ __ ] chain
I feel I feel like it's turning around a
little bit it's turning around for the
it girls
okay okay and and the fat black girls
that never went away I and the the cute
little ink girls are are really hot
right now all right and and it's a shame
that that they have to be that I
normally would never qualify a stand-up
comic based on their sexuality my wife
is a female comic and she's got damn
funny there's the it's unfortunate
though that in that you know the the
it's either no meth there was very
little middle ground it's either either
the theory of the big girl okay and
there Melissa McCarthy right or they're
the hot girl there Jenny McCarthy right
and there's really no in-between you
know there's really no just you know six
or seven right now I mean Amy Schumer is
under constant pressure to lose weight
and stay beautiful and do her hair and
do everything that she has to do Whitney
Cummings is a slave to your own success
as far as the expectations she can't
just put on if i compare you know a
shitty clothes and go out go out you
know it's like they they've been you
know of chelsea peretti same thing okay
and and you know it's it's they become
trapped in what society says they must
be you know look at Kathy Griffin I mean
she's released so many specials that if
she was a man she would be like one of
the greatest stand-ups in the world ok
and should be known and instead she's
regulated it's just being loud and and
always you forget though she's
emmy-nominated you know she's put out I
think with 12 specials or some [ __ ] like
that yeah I mean you know she's been on
TV for 20 [ __ ] years you know give
her a little bit of respect but nobody
does you know it's like like almost like
Joan had started to get respect after
she lost it
you know for so many years and then and
then she was getting you know back on TV
and and out of the plastic surgery her
running to it and said away from it I
endeared her to people and her constant
but she went through people forget she
was ostracized she was thrown out of
show business basically you know when
Johnny Carson I was to squash on you the
squash is on you I mean it's [ __ ]
real all right and you know four
networks at the time only you know what
else you gonna do you know you've given
the chance to host the [ __ ] you know
the late-night talk show and and she was
the first she was before Chelsea she was
before all right you know she's bad lady
don't ever forget it yeah you know and
it's like she was in her like the prime
like people forget you know she was
bankrupt in the 90s completely bankrupt
and she died with over a hundred and
forty million worth over 140 million
dollars you know yeah that's that's
remarkable she also and she hustled and
she did it through being a stand-up yep
you know I mean she or she got on TV but
show me she got on TV was cuz she was a
stand-up and you know so I'm always she
had Paul's man she had [ __ ] balls and
in a time where you saw so much change
in political correctness I me when she
was she was up there doing color jokes
in the 40s okay the coloreds all right
you know all right you know the Negroes
okay all right and now she's [ __ ] you
know now she's this icon that you knows
career spans 70 years or 60 years you
know it's pretty [ __ ] incredible
she's pretty amazing you know and it's
like that's the type of stuff that that
should be talked about but Comedy
Central didn't even have her on you know
and she was an icon and Comedy Central
you know 10 have her on the roast you
know me she should be up there [ __ ]
killing people you know she should have
been crushing them yeah you know
roast it's like they take people and
they make them stars and then they don't
have them on the roast anymore doesn't
make any sense you know it's like you
you brought jelinek to me why why is it
just the next still coming at me all
right I like that guy is funny you know
um I you know you got so you know you
got Lisa Lampanelli whatever to hurt
where's she at yeah yeah captive it's
just that you know you you miss people
you know and it's like they you know
they not for nothing I don't really want
to hear Shaq tell Rosa I don't want I
don't want I don't want Ludacris at a
roast yeah I'm sorry ya know a lot of
people agree with you I you know I see a
lot of comments online like you know
wire that you know they're just getting
these like you know these a list
celebrities to just write you up there
and butcher some great jokes that you
know John fernan er you know Sarah Tiana
or somebody [ __ ] wrote right you know
and it's like why are why are they doing
this you know it's white why is I don't
get it I don't you know they don't make
any sense to me you know it's like you
you build this up it's like why not cash
in on it you know it's like if I was a
network I would want to have the
especially Comedy Central I'd be
sponsoring Comedy tours every year and
doing live remotes from from you know
hype it and make it you know like MTV
back of the day when MTV to a concert it
was a [ __ ] event you were glued to
your TV watching this event why isn't
the oddball festival sponsored by Comedy
Central and available like HBO does
uncensored on it's like you know it's
rock and roll hall of fame show ya what
I mean it's like
why aren't they doing that you know when
they why are they making stand up more
you know enough for nothing but [ __ ]
another episode of futurama sake of it I
was think of it I'm [ __ ] tired of it
you know go out and find me another Matt
Stone and Trey Parker yeah all right
instead of instead of showing me shows
and buying shows and investing in the
past invest in the future okay you know
it's like I want to see the next Judd
Apatow I want to see the next I want I
want I want a comic too I want a drama
about comedy yeah I want a real show
about stand-ups about about the [ __ ]
that real comics go through in New York
and LA and and have a lawn order SVU
franchise okay or CSI franchise when it
comes a comedy you know instead of crime
scene it's comedy scene investigation I
want to see I want to see what it's like
you know to be that guy on the road I
want to see what it's like I want people
to know our story here all right just
like musicians want people to know the
struggle and those movies have always
been successful and TV shows about
making it sure you know that's what I
think that we could do and we're not and
it's like we could do more to elevate
our art for what it really is and yet we
constantly lowest denominator you know
or we don't or Comedy Central will take
I mean a networker and I don't mean just
to slam on Comedy Central that's not
what this is about it's just just a
prime example of our talents being lost
right just just as MTV lost in the
corner on music videos now people don't
even make music videos or they just go
straight to you two yeah yep you know
it's like we used to use to have Rome
use to get any time you can just press
both lives there yeah and
honestly it should be that way with
stand-ups you know you should you should
have that ability to get a comedy
whatever you want it wherever you want
it and what kind you want it you know
from whoever you want and that's why
I've never been into really [ __ ] talk at
other comics you know about about you
know [ __ ] on what kind of comedy
they do right because if you do comedy
at all and you make someone laugh all
right that that lets them know that
their hunger for something they didn't
even know they were hungry for yeah all
right and that hunger drives them to get
more laughter and which means eventually
that hunger is going to drive them to me
which means they're going to be fed by
me and I think I can feed them more than
everybody else you know yeah i think i
think i can feel more jokes i can come
back eight nine months with a new hour
and a half and and many people can do
that it's like that type of mentality
has always served me well where's like a
like it's kind of cool to have a
contempt for your audience it seems like
nowadays like the the laconic has
contempt for the stand up for them for
the audience without them you're just a
[ __ ] guy babbling to yourself yeah
you know I mean it's like you you gotta
kind of give them some kind of respect
you know it's like you know you came out
here you you need me in your life to
make you laugh I understand that and
that need okay or maybe you just want to
laugh all right maybe you don't need
maybe just want right all right whatever
reason drove you here you're here all
right I'm gonna give me that I'm gonna
give you the best i can write and not a
lot of people come with that attitude
you know that of and I'm sorry I'm
stuffy that's all right sinuses I made
it goes from [ __ ] freezing die now 72
[ __ ] ice cream Peter the [ __ ] is going
on with the weather uh
you know I i think that people have a
chance to be better in to be better
performers if they just engage the
audience and respect to the more yeah
you know if they knocked off this
contempt for the audience they'd be
better served when when you were when
you were just starting out when you were
young uh what was your perception like
or did you even think about like
standing you know you're talking about
like how it would be great if people
would know the the the stories of
stand-up comedians when you were in that
well how long were you in Tennessee
before you move to arkansas but so when
i was a kid yeah um we moved what I was
sakes okay and what was I mean you you
brought up you know that you know if you
think that and I agree with us that a
lot of stand-up comedians like it's all
kind of comes from their upbringing
their home life so what was like white
well first of all why did you move from
Tennessee to Arkansas but mom and dad
got divorced when I was two and my mom
well being a very lovely woman is very
flawed financially hmm and she's just
trying to do the best she could and she
did what a lot of people would do they
ran home to mama and her mother and
father were very well off in this small
town in Arkansas and it was a different
time then and she moved back to gain
some respectability yeah and be nearer
to family you know and which is a very
poor move she sold she couldn't have
sold the house in Tennessee at a worse
time and then she didn't buy again and
so taxes ate her up and and we ended up
living in
a red house that you could see through
the walls and places her holes and stuff
and in the winter there'd be so much
plastic it looked like death she was
about to kill somebody it was a an
interesting event trust me it was not
something that you would that you would
figure a millionaire would come from
yeah it's like I remember so many times
in the winner get waking up at night and
saved my breath and then like having
like like the the frosted they formed up
from where I was breathing on that Wow
it was you we were under so many
blankets you know to keep warm and like
I said somebody turned the oven on there
was no hate you know it was interesting
you know and you had you had siblings or
yes yes I have two older sisters one
older brother and a half sister younger
my my brothers a dick yeah you mentioned
that in the special yeah i was gonna ask
if that was based on reality that's real
what's his deal why not that we have
done like I'm not gonna get it all right
thank bad to him he was just a major ass
a couple years ago I tried to kill me
and and I just have a doctor says you
know and it's it's not the usual brother
threatened to kill you all right when
you believe him you believe yeah all
right I believed it so I just stay away
from he's younger than you older older
Wow and so all right so you were so you
were living in that house for a few
years or yeah
we lived in there for 10 years Wow take
that in my grandma's house okay then
with me by the way that's not some
problem with this a podcast that's the
air generated on my bus I'm sorry
everybody the whole bus operates by air
the doors the seals everything the whole
suspension and so that's what that noise
is if you wonder sorry oh that's okay
I'm sorry that's all right no I get
annoying I don't think I don't think
it's gonna get picked up okay wat good
good I don't want to be embarrassed now
oh look was that noise Jane yeah we
moved we were that horrible house and
Clarksville for 10 years 10 12 years
that I moved to Houston and in Houston i
was i felt like i was born again you
know it was awesome and then it's weird
when i made the next move to Los Angeles
I felt born again again you know it was
incredible it was like it's like my life
the more I live it has only gotten
better it's not gotten worse yeah it's
like it was so shitty in the beginning
okay that I guess it can only go better
but you know you know from I was six
weeks old with my alcohol and his whole
family died in a plane crash she comes
to see us he had a mountain I you know
it's it's like one thing after another
after another after the other dear god
it's like you you live all this stuff
and and
used to sit back you just go wow what a
crazy life and then now I've got you
know not only do I have a house to live
in I've got two at a bus okay the child
of divorce has a beautiful wife two
wonderful children that are it's like
when I've got everything that I've ever
wanted it more than I ever thought I
would get you know and it's I'm just so
[ __ ] lucky you know it's like I'm
lucky [ __ ] bum I don't think people
really registered that you know they
don't they don't they don't consider
themselves lucky very often and it's
it's a shame you know you there's
something to be said for luck you know
I'd rather be lucky than then [ __ ]
blessed you know yeah me I'd rather be
lucky and fat if I got uh not lucky and
perfectly there cuz you'll die of
something else you get hit by a piano or
so yes it'll happen to you life will
have a way of [ __ ] making it happen
for you yeah sure yeah people can die
yeah man yeah yeah I think I think a lot
of people just are constantly comparing
whatever situation they and I and I do
this constantly I know I should be
happier than I than I am uh but it's
like well what is that person doing and
and you're constantly comparing and it's
so toxic it's so so taxed for you it
really has been coveting others it will
kill you instead of coming coveting
others will drive you [ __ ] crazy I
almost got caught up in that I mean when
when you see people that you know you're
funnier than the getting [ __ ] TV and
[ __ ] and it drives you [ __ ] nuts
until you realize that that was always
gonna happen right person
regardless of you hating that person or
not isn't right that person's turn was
that person's turn and whatever factors
led to them being there that's where
they are all right so don't begrudge
their [ __ ] success emulated see how
when they did it and if I can replicate
it you know and get your own success
it's always been amazing to me it's like
you know it's like every year or every
couple years like society brings a new
black comic okay you know and and it's
like like there's new renaissance of
great black comedy which is always been
there they've always been [ __ ] funny
yeah okay and there's never been just
only one okay but but mainstream society
only sees one black guy at a time it was
Richard Pryor then it was Eddie Murphy
than it was Chris Rock and then it was
Dave Chappelle and it was Katt Williams
and now it's Kevin Hart yep okay and
it's like America only sees one black
person is funny in a time and it's so
[ __ ] humiliating to us that's all we
can handle around one black guy that's
it guy all right we've got one black guy
to Jews and one Mexican one chick okay
two white guys that's it that's it
that's all they give us and and we're
expected to [ __ ] die on that alone
you know you're those those people are
expected to be everywhere and do
everything oh that is qualified as funny
yeah you know I mean the chicks they
only let us have one or two chicks at
the time okay you know instead of giving
us all these funny you know they now
Sarah Silverman is the end-all be-all of
funny checks okay you know we'll give
her an award okay we'll give the one
girl an award but but all those other
hundreds and hundreds and thousands of
women out there doing stand-up comedy
we're gonna take a big oh [ __ ] on them
okay but we gave one award away so right
okay so we're covered see well
we don't hate women we don't hey with a
copy we don't think last level it's like
how demeaning are you I mean really I
mean the fact that you think that that
will suffice is the meaning in general
you know what I mean it's like it's the
whole idea that only one Black Comet can
be the comic okay is offensive it's
amazingly offensive yeah and yet it
happens continuously and we get told to
that one person is hot over and over and
over again and we believe the [ __ ]
all right and legitimately there they
are very talented but there's also
legitimately very talented other people
out there you know with Chris Rock was
starting out Bernie Mac was burning it
up yeah okay if you watch me back to
back all right as far as laughter goes
like you didn't hear with the comment
saying the audience was laughing hard to
connect any Chris Rock yeah and even
Chris will tell you that okay um but
Chris hit when he wasn't supposed to he
was supposed to have already been a bust
you know more Michaels dismissed him
they fired him alright and so he went
out did at the old fashioned way I'm one
of the few people that worked with Chris
when he was going to stand up to the
clubs yeah after Saturday Night Live we
were working in Houston together and and
we were like this budget loved one is
the biggest piece of [ __ ] ever all right
we were just too they're gonna [ __ ]
hate this guy me to Haiti that's what we
bonded was ain't no [ __ ] clever
perfect eighth but he he and I were
actually talking jokes and he would work
on him at night you know it's weird you
know ten years later to be friends with
his brother
what the [ __ ] you know it's like he got
up blown up and then two years later I'm
with his little brother Tony at my
apartment and on Gardner in LA yeah my
barbecue you know Tony's in there
playing video games like it's crazy you
know it's like a very strange
combination the way life is happening
waits unfolded yeah well you've done
well Ralphie and you should be proud of
yourself thanks and I really do
appreciate you taking the time to chat
Rob alright guys thanks Ralphie and
there you have it Ralphie May on the
last spin podcast thank you so much guys
for tuning in like I said subscribe
thank you so much to Ralphie May for
taking the time to chat be sure to check
out Ralphie on the road be sure to check
them out on netflix his new special
unruly is there now streaming check it
out and we'll see you soon guys bye
you